[Music]
in cannibal criminal news submitted by
lots of pillows a man was arrested for
biting chunks out of the face and arm of
a clerk oh I don't even get his teeth
there he Mike Tyson is that I wonder how
hard it is to take a chump out of us
like skin fuzziest vodka really dig
about you if you're eating steak yes
is that is it the same thing but it's
cooked yeah
does that help I think cooking the meat
helps you break it down that's why good
not really because when you when you
overcook it it's tough as [ __ ] but then
that's how you we get medium-rare and
it's anything the meat is softer when
it's uncooked yeah sure yeah it's softer
yeah what if I can't reach it I don't
they'll rip it right off okay mm-hmm to
me it's chewier so it's not tougher but
I feel like it takes a while to stem
from like human meat but if you smoke
enough crack you can do it easy was he
on crack not that I know
Oh seems like a crappy thing to do so
this this guy's name is Joel well Joel
he's 19 years old and it's happened in
Massachusetts so he was stealing a
bottle drink from a cooler and a gas
station clerk like confronted him about
it
he was thirsty and that's when he just
attacked him see he's like well if
you're not gonna let me drink this I'm a
drink of blood so he bit actually yeah
you're not far off you said you also had
a cape and a mean widow's peak yeah geez
you and that Wales beaver you can't drop
the widow's peak okay no it'll fit
someday I just imagine all the villains
having the mean ol wittle people have us
calipers you just offended all of
Eastern Europe yeah you have a widow's
peak yeah yeah I have a little you're
evil
okay he so after he bit the flesh he
said I don't eat flesh I just drink
blood and then licked his fingers once
that's a sick thing to say before
locking your fingers it is see he was
thirsty
I asked us do you start like
like did he say that like in between
bites he it was after the fight
that's a nasty this is [ __ ] chica yes
was this guy one sandals which one the
clerk Biden was this kind of looking at
knife in a 1980s movie Oh Joel you look
like a vampire [ __ ] seize them MUA what
is he on youtube I don't know oh [ __ ]
bit him in the eye and then the I was
hoping it was down here oh my gosh what
is that that's like his elbow again are
out of control
vampire right there yes this is like he
was finger-painting with the blood wait
is that him yeah this is a Buick he
wasn't on drugs just like a crazy
[ __ ] he probably has a widow's
peak and wearing sandals you're painting
with blood and he wasn't on anything
what is this what are these images from
it looks like it's like behind the
scenes of a George Romero movie okay
posing for his mugshot you have to do
that though think about it cuz then they
got your mugshot forever there's some
good celebrity ones of the guys smiling
because they know at least you can't use
it against me Paris Hilton's is
beautiful
is it yeah why does she have a mug shot
for woke okay she got a rest I think it
was DUI yeah I think you're right and
she's like mmhmm like some sure like
that it was she was my my Tyra was so
happy that they tell you don't smile you
got to look straight but if you don't
listen they're like [ __ ] it
yeah if I was arrested I would smile
usually that's the one that's going on
the news I would wink one of these there
you I mean really smile just like
hilarious he's so scared shitless I'm
just like then you look guilty already
yeah well I definitely said it cause I
got to play the game yeah [ __ ] doubt me
you gotta treat it like it's a real
estate mugshot do I know why does
McNulty and like all these guys not do
this [ __ ] they're always like the most
[ __ ] in the big name is like look just
give it something you're innocent till
proven guilty I'm guilty first you have
to look guilty - yeah Pam yeah so the
[ __ ] up thing is that the store clerk
knew Joel and he had it allegedly stolen
from the store before my gosh and then
oh it's because a witness was saying
that that store clerk he's like the
sweetest it's always a sweet ones that
get [ __ ] up it was an innocent worker
just trying to do his job and try to
prevent the theft of merchandise see
that's that's why I'm not sweet because
that witness I'm saying that said all
this he held down Joel and waited for
the end that's real oh that's brave
because when you smell sweetness you
smell victim that's why you're not sweet
mm-hmm I'm sour
I see yeah yes oh then they're saying
that when an officer asked him about the
victims missing flesh
Joel responded with I got hungry I think
I ate it you can cut my stomach open to
check my why is he such an extra bad
Peyer have you gay that's why yes yeah
so whatever gay people do it's
heightened yes he went in like he's
biting ma'am he's giving his little
punchline oh I don't want me talking
about it's the most extra this only a
gang could do this crazy he's crazy so
now he's being held without bail and
he's ordered to undergo a mental
evaluation yeah yeah this fool is gonna
come back he's [ __ ] batshit crazy I
know I really didn't see them before on
YouTube I swear you have a beauty
channel I'm not even kidding
yeah that looks like some kind of album
cover to it yeah that was like they had
a [ __ ] flashbulb take the picture
[ __ ] ten know a few witnesses do you
think you'd be able to attack him or
what no he's a biter
person like I owe people from me is like
I get upset I get upset when people like
honk at a whole person crossing the
street like I just I can't have you ever
talked at all person and then you never
know but then you you don't know it's a
person and then you see it and you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah oh my god
okay I've done it dry then yeah I I
honked and tailgated a whole person
because I thought they were on their
phone but it was they're just old and
they were driving slow first thing like
on their phone and like [ __ ] I was
like man why the [ __ ] you're doing that
and I pull up it was just a grandpa that
was driving like that and I'm like I'm a
[ __ ] face yeah but then I'm on but then
I always like make myself feel a little
better I'm like well they shouldn't be
driving I do see that too I still feel
good I get thrown off like 30 seconds of
stuff 55 in case I think when there's a
crazy person and they're biting other
people I will run I am NOT brave because
there's two types of people I will not
fight crackheads and crazy people which
or sometimes are the same
interchangeable yeah people that are on
drugs they have superhuman strength yeah
and they'll do anything like they don't
fight fair don't bite your nuts for fun
yeah I think you don't think it's a hot
dog and then start eating it
yeah with someone crazy I don't think I
would intervene it try to comment on
what you what do you can't you can't
talk him down or do anything what's
crazy is when I was a kid I was like I
will stand up and I will do the right
thing but then as soon as you're an
adult and you realize that you could die
like like I'm like [ __ ] Tobey Maguire
and spider-man like a bad guys coming
towards me and I'm like getting out of
the way you know I mean I don't want
anything to do with it cuz I believe
that I could die and you know what's
gonna happen that's true when you're a
kid you want to be a superhero yeah
we're closer to death now that we're
older I don't think death
I think hospital bills I think my
insurance I think like the time away
from work I'm thinking await
responsibilities [ __ ] I think I could
get crackhead rabies like if they bite
me then I'm gonna be a crackhead zombie
you will be I don't know man when I read
that here I clicked it too much no can't
we be well in Florida messages usually
is
usually yes I wonder I feel like this
guy planned it all out or like no it's
just too perfect to be like yeah the
one-liner is all prepared and everything
I get it he couldn't get the wing for
the eyeliner down and this one was going
up and then this was probably going down
I get your [ __ ] frustration because
my [ __ ] I can't get it even he was like
I'm having a [ __ ] bad day just let me
on my [ __ ] drink and then this guy
tip can you show this story to Casey
because I recently we were we were all
having a writer's meeting and Casey was
like I just think it's really
unrealistic in movies when people like
like like they lick a knife and they're
like they're like I'm thirsty and I only
drink blood and I'm like well this is
[ __ ] real dude people actually he's
like do real people actually say [ __ ]
and it's like actually Casey check your
email I don't know what he's so obsessed
with making fantasy be as close to
reality as possible I'm like what it's a
movie enjoy the goddamn movie it doesn't
like he told me doesn't like pork rinds
yeah like lines like in die hard yeah
where it's almost like poetry like the
way like it has a snap to it
you became a [ __ ] like shot yeah
he doesn't like lines like that these
are the memorable lines like the only
movie lights but that's what more reason
why he told me didn't like Game of
Thrones because all the lines are too
poetic so so then he should have watched
reality TV but he doesn't like reality
TV exactly I was like my [ __ ]
marriage he digs back he likes the most
realistic mundane [ __ ] he likes those
like mega
artsy films I have like no irony he
wants to see a human being breathe for
15 minutes filled in feel emotions like
his whole thing is like real raw emotion
from like their acting did you come to
LA to be an actor no awesome because so
many people do and I've learned to be
around like more gay people and just
diversity there's not that many gay
people where you came from I'm sure
there were but according to pornhub
there is what corner pornhub searches in
the [ __ ] like Missouri and all that [ __ ]
so I got some of the highest that's
freaks everywhere I mean like a
community now I wasn't big
now Koreatown uh-oh I lived in good time
I love it there's a lot gay people
Koreatown no but I go - WeHo like to LA
in general like African did date yeah
it's so much more how come not San
Francisco but LA cuz San Francisco's
like really gay and more diverse wait
you think la is more diverse in San
Francisco yeah as far as like black
people as far as just don't like that
from the city rain oh I feel like I'm
whatever it is bigger because San
Francisco is pretty small anyway more
expensive very techie but don't you
think they're virgins kind of like a
middle-aged white person living next to
a young white person living next to old
white person isn't that kind of
diversity yeah it's like a hipster agree
to it if I walk down the street in LA I
will see more people that look like me
and if I walk down the street
this happens yeah but when I'm watching
a movie and I'm like oh there's a brown
haired white guy and there's a blonde
haired what kind of talking to each
other like this is a pretty diverse I
feel that way I don't I don't like
diversity unless they're all
good-looking
[Music]